what is your assessment of Ben Shapiro's
debating style his ethical consistency
his ability to deploy logic etc etc he
has obviously an incredibly High verbal
IQ he can construct a sentence out of
nowhere and do it very quickly and he's
also very difficult to interrupt not
that I particularly wanted to he would
throw sort of maybe two or three points
out at once and and you want to Bud in
and do them one by one you don't want to
be rude of course so I let him finish
but it was amazing how they just glued
together into one wall of text I think
in many ways he matches the energy that
he given and so taking him seriously and
listening to what he's saying and being
willing to concede a point to him he
will do the same thing it's a hidden
humility because it comes out not in the
attitude he's not going to like give way
to you emotionally he's not going to be
like oh you're right if you pay
attention to the way he's constructing
an argument and changing it subtly based
on your responses you know that he
really is listening and really is trying
to engage with what you're actually
saying and that's the kind of humility
that I don't think can really be faked